Speaker 1: All right. One really funny other thing
related to YouTube channels and then we're going
to move on to a bunch of other things. You may or
may not know that we launched a second or really a
third YouTube channel recently, and it is called
Pacman Finance. Okay. This is not a political
channel. This is a channel in which we do personal
finance and a little light economics. So how to
put together an asset allocation? Why is some
inflation good? Why you shouldn't try to time the
market. All these things so funny. Initially when
we launched the channel, a bunch of right wingers
were like, Dude, you're a socialist, why are you
going to give financial advice? And some of them
have tomatoes. Canadian turned around. I love
this. This guy, Tommy boy. Okay. After we posted
our first video, he wrote, This is comical, a
complete socialist talking about asset allocation,
laughable hypocrisy. Now, of course, I'm not a
socialist, but he was entitled to his opinion.
The second video we posted, Tommy Boy shows
up and he says, Dude, you really going to keep
talking out of both sides of your mouth on two
channels? Be a capitalist or be a socialist. Stop
trying to pretend you can be both. Now, having a
budget doesn't exactly make you one or the other.
But anyway, Tommy Boy is entitled to his opinion.
And then just yesterday, Tommy Boy shows up after
like our sixth video and says Pacman gives sound
conservative financial advice on this channel.
Ignore his utter nonsense political advice on
the other channel and just watch this channel.
Tommy Boy has been turned around 180 degrees by
the sensible and sound information. Remember,
I'm not giving any individual financial advice,
but the information on the Pacman Finance Channel,
I invite you to check it out. YouTube.com, slash
Pacman finance. We've got clips going up about
all sorts of different topics. And if you have
a finance topic you would like me to address,
not politics folks. Different
channel, not politics. You can
email info at David Pakman dot com and I will
do my very best to address that. And soon we'll
be taking some personal finance questions
for the channel. Lots of exciting things
coming up. All right. We have a fantastic show
tonight. It is betto versus abbott debate for
texas governor. I will be live on youtube,
twitch and facebook for that debate. I hope
you will join me. I don't know exactly what time
it is. Must be sometime around 7pmi don't know.
And I hope to see everybody then. The David Pakman
Show is a viewer and listener supported program.
It's the audience that funds the work that we do,
primarily through the bonus show and full show
made available through the membership program.
Speaker 2: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: I welcome you and invite you with peace
and love to sign up at join Packman dot com and
you can use the coupon code big voting 22 to get
a discount off of the cost of your membership.